four American Service members and a
military service dog wounded in a U.S
counter-terrorism raid in Syria U.S
officials say their target senior Isis
leader Hamza alhamzi was killed in the
helicopter raid but they say he
detonated a suicide vest as troops
closed in on him in Northeast Syria
Christina raffini is at the White House
with the latest on this Christina good
morning
good morning Jeff three of those four
injured troops were transferred to an
American Military Hospital in Germany
for further treatment meanwhile U.S
Central Command says on that same night
it launched a separate raid on another
Isis assassination cell leader that raid
was successful there were no injuries
but both of these incidents are an
important reminder that the battle
against Isis is ongoing
while the Northwest side of Syria
grapples with the devastating human toll
of last week's catastrophic earthquake
in the East U.S and local Syrian forces
are and have been engaged in a constant
battle to keep the malignant presence of
Isis in remission
U.S Special operators targeted Hamza
alhamzi he was overseeing the group's
deadly terrorist Network in eastern
Syria before he was killed in the raid
U.S forces took helicopters to a
nondescript home which they surrounded
but as they closed in on their target an
explosion either a suicide vest or a
booby trap went off the troops and the
working dog are in stable conditions are
being treated at a U.S military facility
100 American troops are still stationed
in Syria working with local Syrian
forces to prevent Isis from staging a
comeback in the last year no American
forces were killed or wounded but it's a
deadly and Dangerous Game of Hide and
Seek in a landscape that's anything but
stable
what we don't know yet are how the
aftershocks of this earthquake both
political and physical will impact this
fight already there are reports that
there was physical damage to a prison
near the Turkish border that enabled
about 20 Isis fighters to escape
Michelle
yes a ripple effect certainly Christina
thank you